[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen an diesen
achtzehnter juli norbert lehmann ist
auch dabei für den sport von mir und das
sind die nachrichten themen von heute
konzepte gegen die klimakrise angesichts
zunehmender wetter extreme beraten 40
länder in berlin über auswege und
deutschland bereitet sich auf die große
hitze vor
kein striktes nein längere laufzeiten
bei atomkraftwerken
werden doch noch mal geprüft im gegenzug
können sich cdu politiker ein
befristetes tempolimit vorstellen
und die schnellste frau der welt
shelly-ann fraser-pryce jamaika läuft in
den usa zu ihrem fünften wm gold über
100 meter und zum wm-rekord
hitze dürre waldbrände auch europa
bekommt hautnah die wetter- extreme zu
spüren allein deutschland kostet der
klimawandel mittlerweile
durchschnittlich 6,6 milliarden euro pro
jahr sagt das wirtschaftsministerium in
berlin beim petersberger klimadialog
versuchen vertreter aus 40 ländern
antworten zu finden entweder wir handeln
zusammen oder wir gehen gemeinsam
selbstmord wand un-generalsekretär
guterres simon 20 berichtet
hier viel zu viel wasser
da schon lange gar kein wasser mehr es
sind bilder die unterschiedlicher kaum
sein könnten was sie eint ist dass es im
zuge des klimawandels noch mehr davon
geben wird die klimakrise ist
mittlerweile das größte
sicherheitsproblem für alle menschen auf
dieser erde deswegen werden wir die
klimakrise nur gemeinsam in den griff
bekommen es geht heute in berlin darum
wie ärmeren ländern geholfen werden kann
aber es geht auch darum wie deutschland
seine klimaziele erreichen will während
gerade kohlekraftwerke reaktiviert
werden niemand kann zufrieden sein damit
das auch bei uns der anteil der
kohleverstromung gerade wieder steigt
als reaktion auf drohende engpässe bei
der gasversorgung
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir eines
ganz klar festhalten
dass es eine zeitlich eng befristete
notmaßnahme die nicht zu lasten unserer
klimaziele geht der krieg in der ukraine
hat die klimapolitik zurückgeworfen
viele entwicklungsländer fürchten
vergessen zu werden der ägyptische
präsident erinnert heute daran dass
afrika am heftigsten vom klimawandel
betroffen sei die jüngsten
nahrungsmittel und energie krisen haben
die herausforderungen verschärft mit
denen die afrikanischen länder
konfrontiert sind und das noch
zusätzlich zu der realen bedrohung die
der klimawandel für uns darstellt also
verwüstung wasserknappheit der steigende
meeresspiegel
verheerende fluten wie hier in burundi
100 milliarden dollar jährlich haben die
industriestaaten ärmeren ländern im
kampf gegen den klimawandel versprochen
jetzt müsse das geld auch fließen
fordern experten
ich glaube das ist sehr wichtig vor
allem für die länder des globalen südens
dass sie merken es geht nicht nur um die
absichtserklärungen sondern die wirklich
wichtige währung zur zeit sind
glaubwürdige zu sagen vier monate noch
bis zur weltklimakonferenz in ägypten es
gibt noch viel zu tun
der klimawandel belastet auch die
hiesige landwirtschaft hitze und
trockenheit führen zu früheren und zum
teil auch zu geringeren ernten die böden
leiden schon länger seit dem dürfe
sommer 2018 fehlt es vielerorts an
wasser und bot feuchtigkeit wind kann
den ausgetrockneten oberboden leicht
vortragen und wenn es stark regnet kann
der durch getrocknete boden die
plötzlichen wassermassen nicht aufnehmen
wertvolle erdschichten werden einfach
weggespült
langfristig sinkt dann auch der
grundwasserspiegel der könnte sich nur
durch ausreichend niederschlag erholen
doch wenn der ausbleibt verschärft sich
die boden situation jahr für jahr aus
sachsen anhalt berichtet laura wiedeking
eigentlich sollte dieser weizen noch
etwas grün sein und wachsen doch wegen
der trockenheit ist er notreife und
landwirt eckhard o man muss mit der
ernte anfang die kölner sind kleiner er
rechnet mit einbußen von bis zu 30
prozent gute jahre können bei uns auch
trocken jahre seien aber dann müssen wir
hohe grundwasserstände haben und wenn
die trockenheit aber so groß ist dass
der grundwasserstand so stark sinkt dann
können die pflanzen von und kein wasser
mehr holen und dann ist jede trocken und
hitzeperioden im frühjahr natürlich
schon deutlich für die pflanzen andere
pflanzen trocken resistente sorten eine
wasser schonende bodenbearbeitung seit
jahren pastor man sich an die
klimawandel bedingte veränderungen des
wetters an
andere landwirte setzen auf bewässerung
zum beispiel beim gemüseanbau aber was
heißt ein knappes gut das weiß auch
bernhard krüsken vom bauernverband es
brauche eine strategie für die
bewässerung
wir haben jetzt im moment drei prozent
der fläche in der berechnung das können
wir nicht unendlich ausbauen aber für
das was jetzt in der berechnung ist
brauchen wir natürlich die
bereitstellung von wasser riss die
landwirtschaftlichen flächen die
bewässert werden müssen werden zunehmen
wie viel das ist noch die frage und auch
woher das wasser kommen soll nicht
unnötig flächen versiegelt sei ein
schritt so sven schultze vorsitzender
der agrarministerkonferenz
hier in sachsen anhalt haben
beispielsweise uns vorgenommen das war
das wassermanagement verändern wollen
wir haben ja in den letzten jahrzehnten
hier situationen gehabt dass man wasser
versucht hat immer abzuleiten wir müssen
das aber wieder sammeln wir müssen das
staunen das heißt wir müssen ganz anders
denken zurzeit brauchen vor allem noch
mais rüben oder auch sonnenblumen wasser
sie werden erst im herbst geerntet wie
diese ernte dann ausfällt das hängt von
der aktuellen hitzewelle ab
schauen wir auf die aktuellen
temperaturen die hitzewelle aus
südeuropa erreichte heute den westen
deutschlands mit temperaturen bis 36
grad am rhein und mosel morgen ist
möglicherweise der heißeste tag mit bis
zu 40 grad am niederrhein am mittwoch
zieht die große hitze dann in den osten
deutschlands auch dort erwarten
meteorologen 40 grad in stuttgart war es
heute schon ziemlich heiß berichtet
weltklasse
die sonne sticht vom wolkenlosen himmel
gnadenlos macht den stuttgarter
schlossplatz zum glutofen
36 grad zeigt das thermometer am späten
nachmittag sonnenplätze sind da nicht
sonderlich begehrt natürlich
komme aus argentinien es habe ich den
schirm mitgenommen sonst wäre ich gar
nicht mehr gekommen also ich bin heute
lieber zuhause ehrlich gesagt besonders
belastend ist dieses wetter für ältere
menschen und die die ohne viel schatten
körperlich hart arbeiten müssen so wie
rob in schwerin ja weil wir das aber es
nützt nichts die arbeit muss gemacht
werden
an die kühlere nordseeküste hitzestress
unterdessen in stuttgart auch in der
notaufnahme des klinikums wie bereitet
man sich nun auf den höhepunkt der
aktuellen hitzewelle am morgigen
dienstag vor auch in den vergangenen
tagen haben wir viele patienten die
einfach nicht genug getrunken haben die
dehydriert sind und dann zum teil mit
schlaganfall symptomen kommen wo wir
aber letztendlich dann meistens gott sei
dank für stellen das ist eigentlich nur
die fehlende flüssigkeitsaufnahme
baulich bereitet man sich am klinikum
auf zukünftige hitzewellen vor hier
kommt jetzt etwa eine folie auf die
fenster die rund 80 prozent der
sonnenstrahlen abhalten soll insgesamt
werde in krankenhäusern und auch bei den
kommunen aber noch zu wenig getan sagt
expertin franziska mathis wiesler es
leider nicht sehr gut vorbereitet auch
große hitzewellen es gibt nur ganz
wenige städte und kommunen die
hitzeschutz pläne umgesetzt haben anders
als zb in frankreich oder italien
es geht in solchen plänen zum beispiel
darum wie man städte klimagerechte
umbaut aber auch darum was zu tun ist
wenn die hitze akut da ist um die
bevölkerung bestmöglich zu schützen
bei hitze denkt man in der regel nicht
direkt an großbritannien doch auch dort
brechen gerade rekorde morgen könnten es
deutlich über 40 grad werden erstmals
überhaupt gilt eine extreme hitze
warnung einige schulen wurden
geschlossen
mehr krankenwagen in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt die londoner u-bahn muss heute
und morgen mit gedrosseltem tempo fahren
so groß das risiko dass schienen
überhitzen und sich verformen
und im südwesten europas wüten weiter
zahlreiche waldbrände allein spanien
zählte heute 22 und wieder wurde eine
verbrannte leiche gefunden in portugal
haben die feuer in einer woche mehr als
30.000 hektar wald vernichtet von fünf
großen bränden sprechen die behörden an
der französischen atlantikküste mussten
erneut tausende menschen vorsichtshalber
ihre häuser verlassen das 2000
feuerwehrleute versuchen die flammen
unter kontrolle zu bringen
wo stehen wir aktuell bei der
erderwärmung das können sie in unserer
zdf heute app genau nachsehen denn dort
haben wir die wichtigsten zahlen zum
klimawandel zusammengetragen für
deutschland und für die ganze welt
der klimaschutz auf der einen seite der
drohende gas mangel und die energiekrise
auf der anderen beides führt dazu dass
hierzulande atomkraft immer stärker
diskutiert wird eigentlich ist ende des
jahres endgültig schluss doch fdp und
union können sich eine verlängerung
vorstellen und teile der union bieten
jetzt an dafür einem tempolimit
zuzustimmen einen solchen zitat
kuhhandel lehnt die fdp zwar ab dennoch
bewegt sich in sachen atomkraft
möglicherweise was in der ampelkoalition
nico dittmann hat details die letzten
drei kernkraftwerke länger am netz
lassen und ein tempolimit auf deutschen
autobahnen
die cdu macht druck in der debatte um
die energiekrise das tempolimit machten
relativ geringen unterschied beim
energieverbrauch aber wenn die grünen
sagen das ist ja dann ein kompromiss ein
nationaler wir machen bei der
kernenergie für ein halbes jahr länger
eine nutzung in der mange lage dann
finde ich sollten wir auch über ein
tempolimit reden können vernünftiger
kompromiss vorschlag oder eher eine
liste opposition um die amper regierung
zu spalten schließlich gehört der
atomausstieg zur dna der grüne aber das
von ihnen geleitete
wirtschaftsministerium
bestätigt heute man wolle erneut
abklopfen ob man die meiler doch etwas
länger laufen lassen könne
man muss in der krise
situationsangemessen entscheiden und auf
basis von klaren fakten entscheiden auch
das kanzleramt zeigt sich ergebnisoffen
und betont dass die frage
der atomkraftwerke für die
bundesregierung von anfang an keine
ideologische sondern eine rein fachliche
frage gewesen ist und die experten
prüfungen unterlegen hat und jetzt noch
einmal unter verschärften umständen
unterliegen wird ein stresstest also der
nun schnell erkenntnisse bringen soll
fdp grüne und spd aber stecken bereits
mitten drin im stresstest die liberalen
nämlich wollen keinen millimeter von
ihrem strikten nein abrücken dem zum
tempolimit sie sprechen von einem
kuhhandel
beim thema laufzeitverlängerung geht es
ja darum geht es um die frage wie wir
energie sicherheit versorgungssicherheit
in deutschland gewährleisten können dass
wir eine mögliche energielücke in
deutschland schließen können tempolimit
ist kein beitrag dazu die um das problem
der gaskrise energiekrise in deutschland
zu lösen der nutzen einer
laufzeitverlängerung ist jedoch
ebenfalls umstritten die debatte dreht
sich eben auch um prinzipien und
wahlversprechen
bundesjustizminister buschmann will
gewalt gegen frauen künftig strenger
bestrafen konkret sollten
geschlechtsspezifische motive künftig
strafverschärfend wirken sagte er der
funke mediengruppe gewalttaten von
männern gegen frauen dürften nicht als
private tragödien oder als
eifersuchtsdramen bagatellisiert werden
so der fdp politiker
diäten will die ukraine mit weiteren 500
millionen euro für waffen und ausrüstung
unterstützen das kündigte eu
ratspräsident michelle an insgesamt
erhöht sich damit die militärhilfe aus
der eu auf 2,5 milliarden euro wir sind
in der zwanzigsten woche dieses kriegs
der ukraine der ukraine geht nach
eigenen angaben das geld aus und moskau
schon überhaupt nicht daran zu denken
die angriffe einzustellen anton kuschelt
der russische verteidigungsminister auf
truppenbesuch in der ukraine wo genau
ist aus sicherheitsgründen streng geheim
bekannt dagegen der befehl den er
mitgebracht hat die waffensysteme aus
dem westen müssen zerstört werden
ukrainische einheiten hatten in den
letzten tagen mit us raketenwerfern
russische munitionsdepots bombardiert
auch heute werden die heftigsten
gefechte wieder aus der region donetsk
im osten der ukraine gemeldet von da
stammen auch diese bilder zerstörte
getreidesilos und brennende weizenfelder
ist unsere ernte verbrannt von den
russen wir haben es nicht geschafft sie
zu retten dieses gebiet wäre beinahe von
den russen erobert worden sie sind drei
kilometer von hier entfernt
während es hier brennt tut sich in der
ukraine eine weitere front auf offenbar
versucht russland den ukrainischen
sicherheitsapparat zu infiltrieren um
das land auch von innen zu schwächen
präsident selensky suspendierte die
generalstaatsanwältin und den chef des
geheimdienstes fsb der vorwurf sie
hätten nicht genug gegenspionage getan
bis heute wurden 651 strafverfahren
wegen hochverrats von mitarbeitern der
staatsanwaltschaften und
ermittlungsbehörden registriert 60
geheimdienstagenten sind im besetzten
gebiet geblieben und arbeiten gegen
unseren staat
moskau stellte heute noch mal klar die
kampfhandlungen werden erst eingestellt
wenn alle militärischen ziele in der
ukraine erreicht sind
in die usa fast zwei monate ist das
schulmassaker im texanischen juli her
von anfang an hieß es die polizei habe
schwer versagt ein vorwurf den jetzt ein
untersuchungsbericht untermauert 19
kinder und zwei lehrerinnen waren bei
dem blutbad ums leben gekommen was ihre
angehörigen besonders wütend und
fassungslos macht der 18 jährige
angreifer hatte für seine tat weit mehr
als eine stunde zeit bevor die
polizisten ihn in einem klassenzimmer
erschossen elmar theveßen
als es begann waren sie nur wenige das
belegen die dramatischen bilder von den
videokameras der polizisten
aber schon minuten später kam
verstärkung auch staatspolizei
bundesbeamte alle wohl bewaffnet der
untersuchungsausschuss des texanischen
parlaments enthüllt das ausmaß ihres
versagens nach dem bericht waren es am
ende 3 176 sicherheitskräfte keiner
traute sich ins klassenzimmer ihnen war
die eigene sicherheit wichtiger als das
leben der unschuldigen opfer
keine kommandostelle keine kommunikation
systemisches und menschliches versagen
alles was man sich nur vorstellen kann
geschah an diesem tag
sie kamen und warteten und wacht über
eine stunde die angehörigen die die
videos gesehen und den bericht gelesen
haben sind empört über die feigheit der
beamte
als ich nach vietnam geschickt wurde
wusste ich ich würde vielleicht nicht
zurückkehren es war ihre aufgabe da
reinzugehen sie hatten warten was ist
mit den kindern da dran
ich konnte nicht weglaufen warum liefen
sie weg lehrer es wurde selbst verletzt
einer meiner schüler hatte einen bauch
wunder wenn man ihn früher geholfen
hätte hätte er wohl überlebt
viele kinder konnten rechtzeitig fliehen
gerichte sollen nun klären ob einige der
19 schüler und zwei lehrer starben weil
beamte an diesem tag zu lange tatenlos
zusehen aber
schnitt jetzt zur leichtathletik wm
norbert die schnellsten männer der welt
alle aus den usa heute die schnellsten
frauen der welt alle aus dem akja und
eine von ihnen so was von überragend
trotz ihrer 1 mit der 52 körpergröße
shelly ann fraser pryce holt gold über
100 meter ihr fünfter wm titel in
derselben einzeldisziplin das hat noch
keine leichtathletin vor ihr geschafft
sie hat es wieder getan shelly ann
fraser pryce in 10,67 sekunden schneller
als je zuvor in einem wer im finale
[Applaus]
auf bahn sechs staaten trennt die
amerikanerin wie erstmals vor 13 jahren
in berlin auch hier in den usa allen
davon ihr fünfter 100 meter wm triumph
diesmal vor ihren landsfrauen jackson
und olympiasiegerin thompson hier shelly
ann fraser pryce mit 35 jahren so
schnell weil sie eine inspiration für
alle frauen seien wolle ihren eigenen
weg zu gehen ihre motivation genauso
unschlagbar gut wie sie derzeit selbst
zur fußball wm der frauen da haben
gestern schweden und titelverteidiger
niederlande gesiegt und die ko-runde
erreicht das dfb-team das spielt am
donnerstag im viertelfinale gegen
österreich und gönnt sich jetzt aber
erst mal etwas ruhe
untätig allerdings sind sie nicht ein
paar leichtere übungen im teamquartier
die erfolgreiche vorrunde mit drei
siegen war für alle auch anstrengend
jetzt haben sie ein bisschen frei wir
haben gesagt 48 stunden mal abschalten
nicht an fußball zu denken oder wenig an
fußball zu denken der schüler
torschützen gegen dänemark hat ihre
corona erkrankung überwunden ist zurück
im team aber wohl noch keine option für
das viertelfinale geht nach österreich
mit vielen spielerinnen aus der
bundesliga aber das deutsche
selbstbewusstsein ist groß beide
mannschaften haben hohe leidenschaften
roos herz die bessere mannschaft wird
sich durchsetzen und das sind wir dafür
haben sie zuletzt kraft getankt
das bayern team ist heute zu einer
siebentägigen usa reise aufgebrochen
noch ohne den erhofften neuzugang
matthais die luft der muss noch in
münchen zum medizin check und zur
vertragsunterzeichnung
ja und in den usa da zeigte sich heute
ex bayern star robert lewandowski
erstmals in neuer dienstkleidung er
begleitet das team von fc barcelona bei
dessen usa reise schöne aussichten
offenbar
dankeschön sie wissen ja morgen wird's
richtig heiß aber nicht überall wo genau
wo nicht und wie lange sagt gleich ist
intelli christian sievers spricht im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn mit
bahn chef richard lutz wir wünschen
ihnen einen angenehmen abend bis morgen
wenn sie würden
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter mit der klimakrise neben die
hitzetage zu das ist der trend der
vergangenen jahrzehnte und einige witze
tage stehen uns bevor das was sie hier
sehen in rot eingefärbt ist größer als
30 grad und das erwartet uns morgen im
westen sogar bis zu 40 grad diese
hitzeglocke die lange zeit schon vorher
gesagt wurde wandert allmählich am
mittwoch in den osten deutschlands und
in der nacht schnell erzählt kaum was
los kaum wolken und morgen ebenfalls
wenig los vom wetter her es gibt viel
sonnenschein aber die temperatur in der
nacht sind interessant diesen teilweise
um 10 grad im norden 12 grad im südosten
das ist noch mal eine gute gelegenheit
die wohnung ordentlich auszukühlen denn
morgen wird es heiss 40 grad im westen
deutschlands
es kann auch knapp darüber gehen
ansonsten am kühlsten noch mit 25 grad
an der ostsee und übermorgen ist die
hitzeglocke im osten teils 38 bis 40
grad und im westen schwül vor allem dann
mit gewittern die wir an einem unwetter
bereich liegen im osten viel
sonnenschein eben diese 40 grad die tage
darauf nicht mehr ganz so heiß ein
schöner